and don't forget about our Good Day Las  Vegas viewer cookbook we want to see  your recipes we're putting together an  online version of all the best of our  viewers and us we'll post ours as well  send it to picks at 8newsnow.com and we  got this awesome recipe we've got a few  uh cranberry sauce and I love this this  was sent to us by Janine  this is kind of one of my go-to's but I  have never seen it with ghost pepper  before oh boy that's a Nate move right  here sugar honey water and ghost pepper  powder Nate I think you and I might jump  on absolutely and of course I would  probably add a couple of more dashes of  the ghost pepper but you put in as much  as you think you can handle so everyone  can be as red as the cranberry sauce  while they're eating it sure flush yeah  that sounds awesome Janine thanks for  sending that in yeah sounds good bring  them all we want to see them all